[Music]
can I just be like Who I am normally I
think that this seems boring a [ __ ]
you wanted to face them here well who
doesn't want to face the second best
team in the world but every team dezhkin
up against them have played literally
[ __ ] [ __ ] because there is no
personalities nobody stands out I mean I
do all the work cuz I'm the best player
in the world
everyone is just this plan as Pro let's
go says they played well I'm so happy
for them I hope they win nobody does
that
nobody read hope someone else wins I
hope I went with the personalities in
our team we expect ourselves to win
everything we play no excuses now they
have everything to lose now we have Siro
- this is our next month at the end of
the day I think that that team is
nowhere near as successful as we are
nobody's gonna be as dominant as out
together
there's not gonna be this sort of air
ever again Fabien Fabien halston isn't
your typical siege head he wasn't a
prodigy insource
csgo or call of duty he didn't grow up
grinding deathmatch lobbies or
rough-and-tumble rounds of Search and
Destroy Fabien wasn't a Fragger he was a
thinker a strategist it's actually quite
funny because I come from like hardcore
strategy games nothing that sounds like
Age of Empires I come from games like a
ruderal universe always for like a come
at of the world that you use can conquer
with any country you'd like to play so I
come from those games and yet in spite
of his competitive nature Fabien wasn't
particularly drawn to multiplayer in
fact he spent a lot of his time avoiding
servers altogether instead he'd spend
hours pitting himself against the most
obstinate opponent of all the computer
so single-player games can be very
stimulating I feel like if I can
challenge myself and put a difficulty on
a game to one where I actually have to
work really hard to beat it that could
help me more than actually playing
against other players and you can
stimulate my brain into a level where
I will think outside of the box just
because I know I need some other way
than the default way to get through
something that all changed of course
when the Swedish savant first got his
hands on siege a tactical shooter that
let him flex his intelligence over his
aim soon he made it into pro league and
was starting to make a name for himself
baby in a KSP came at the same time for
an easy kill that and they will get back
in and also diffuser with ease fabien
was promising the problem was that his
heart wasn't in it all through here once
it's in 3d the girl from that I was with
currently we broke up and I was feeling
miserably I was pulling it sailing
University but spending too much time
playing and you know like you break up
with your girlfriend nothing feels
really good in life so I decided to quit
the game I was like this is what's
actually ruining things for me three
months later some of my real-life
friends actually buy the game and then
like they have no idea what I level I've
been playing on before they have like
think they don't know me like if they
don't know what I've been doing when I
was viewing it and I was like okay you
guys want to play this game and they're
like yeah sure let's go play together
I'm like I'm pretty good at it
two weeks later I've started talking
with you own us again which is my former
teammate and we've traded a professional
team and come back to pro league the
roster in question was Penta sports
where Fabien not only was given the
chance to play alongside his former
teammates unis but an extraordinary
up-and-comer whose talent Fabien had
spotted a mile away now yogurts coming
around the corner and this is the
headshot cue for Pangu and Pangu still
he's still fighting for his life and
Falco taking outspoken with the team
kill I'm Pangu punishing him
surprisingly enough Fabien decided to
adopt a purposefully nonchalant attitude
towards his prodigal returned to Pro
League me and Jonas holiday what do we
want to do we want to have fun
we love this game we think it's amazing
but it takes too much time to practice
it every day we decided let's just play
for fun practice maybe three times a
week then you have more than enough time
to do whatever you want on the side the
problem of course is that Fabien had a
knack for winning and once he tasted it
it was hard not to keep coming back for
more
it's when we started winning events
because the events paid so much more
than getting my normal salary and I was
gonna be a teacher so for me going from
being a teacher making barely any money
at all to do it full-time in sports for
a decent salary and actually win quite a
lot of money that's when I decided for
me to be full-time over the course of
2017 Penta solidified themselves as the
single most dominant seed roster in
Europe and eventually the world you're
gonna see a dual peak here they're gonna
say look for the corners gonna go one
two three they're gonna go for the shot
and he misses once he's naked look for
the time he gets it and now Jimmy fabien
getting the win for his team granted on
the champions heads is gonna have time
to get the diffuser down and we are
gonna see Penta win this all there the
world champions right now for season one
at a time when siege was still in its
infancy
fabien was strategizing and in game
leading like no other he was able to see
the game in a way that no one not even
his teammates
had ever imagined it must be those
single-player games it has to be like
he's always playing single-player games
take another world you know mastermind
all this I think he's really good at
coming up with unorthodox scenarios or
strategies that works well in the moment
but would name a word long-term under
Fabian's direction Penta became the
fiercest squad and siege and the first
to rack up back-to-back Pro League
titles
with literally V world's best roster at
his disposal and an equally cerebral
coach at his side Fabien established the
greatest dynasty siege has ever seen and
boy did he love to flaunt it
with the personalities in our team we
expect ourselves to win everything we
play look where we are now yours in your
hands to defend well the trophy fit good
in my hand last season it might as well
do this one too but that overconfidence
came to bite Penta in the ass during
their semi-finals against Brazilian
hopefuls black dragons in the third
season of that year's Pro League Julian
a wag can he get it
Bobby's gonna tip around again he won't
get it Giulio get the frag black dragons
goes to the grand final taking down the
last two season duel champion bet the
sports
as much of a fan of Penta as I am I
think this is a slap in the face that
they need it they got way too cocky
especially Fabien and this is the
wake-up call
now you prepare for the Invitational by
being a bit more humble than what you've
been throughout the season we had an
element and overconfidence coming out of
the year to season two which is why I
think we've probably performed so bad in
Brazil Penta had become a little
complacent and even though everyone knew
they were the best team in the world
they'd yet to win the big one the
tournament that would cement them as
gods of the game the Invitational is the
biggest tournament on every single front
every single way and it's where you want
to be it's where you need to be as a
player as a team it's it's whether or
not we can get back on the horse we need
to show that we were able to recover
from the mistakes that we made in Brazil
and that we can continue to innovate and
really push ourselves and innovate they
did after demolishing their group Penta
coasted through the playoffs without
dropping a single map people figure that
pentas grand final matchup against the
rowdy and resilience defending champions
Evil Geniuses would just be a formality
a wash and it was just not in the way
they expected
we lose the first two maps we get
smashed they played so much better than
we did
somehow someway Penta had tripped out of
the gate stunned
scared and on the brink of elimination
they needed Fabien to right the ship to
step up and knock some sense into his
team because God knows they needed it be
happy and I can't be glad and not
shouted you if we don't do our basic
[ __ ]
they are [ __ ] their [ __ ] pants
they have everything to lose now we have
zero - this is our next map you can't
really give yourself hope that needs to
come from someone else when you're down
that was Fabian in that tournament Penta
were pissed pressured and primed to make
the run of a lifetime and that was a
very good play their neck rocks
distracted Fabien taking nvk the second
time around this Monti push that we see
from Penta is absolutely crushing eg now
Canadian once again in a situation where
he will need to clutch a one before take
him down to next Noelle he'll take Koga
but he now has a shield in his way very
difficult with only one build eliminate
amante but Penta takes their first map
round after round map after map Fabien
and his team rallied to versus for unis
from deep inside of the server stairs
we'll get VC on response on to Pangu
there's only one defender left to deny
this and it's not gonna happen
and with eg refusing to give up it was
on the Swede to stay cool in the clutch
Fabien all alone in theater he sticks
the defuser waits for the audio kidney
young will need to cover there is a c4
from Fabien he Prime's a Canadian falls
off he goes down young will need to get
him he has only ten seconds and he
enters they will be in a standoff can he
get the Valkyrie two seconds young
pushes up running out of time No
that's point and then finally in the
last moments of what has since been
dubbed the greatest series of Rainbow
six ever played Penta brought their
unthinkable comeback to a close
the defuser in a position where they'll
have to see when the Habano goes through
one will cover the doorway as they start
to diffusion in the world until today
Penza ardor world champion the
invitation
[Music]
[Applause]
from that point on Fabien rule was
absolute a narrow loss to Team Liquid in
the season 7 finals and an upset at
repack Valencia marked the only two
blemishes on an all but perfect
performance in 2018 and thus Ameen took
shape I mean I do all the work because
I'm the best player in the world that's
great to hear
he's like individually is the worst
player in our team but he still like
manages to be a play so consistently
because he does so such smart moves and
everything and beside telling is the
same Fabien had proven that he was in a
sense the greatest force the game had
ever seen so he decided to run with it
the thing that makes them refer Thomas
that is himself right because he says
I'm the best in the world and the reason
one works is because he isn't right and
he knows that so it's funny me
individually that's obviously a meme you
know I never thought I'd be the best
player ever
it's it's like as soon as someone asked
you who's the best player it's like it's
the easiest way to say you see in
addition to pushing the envelope in game
Fabien was controversial outside of it
too whether he was trying to stir the
pot or just speaking his mind Fabien had
developed a reputation as sieges
resident [ __ ] disturber I just think
that this is plan it's not fun it's not
enjoyable
there's no entertainment value in it the
only thing that's entertainment value
right now is how good we shoot people
there's no entertainment value in the
people actually I'm fine until now
because I have to talk to you Parker and
it's you know it's not the time that I
enjoy the most out of my days it's a
slow day one of us we usually tweet
about the other crew think it's funny
it's good contact we're good friends and
if it's just it plays into like like the
whole like we hate each other and then
people don't understand that it's
theater fabien pretty much had license
to say or do whatever he wanted after
all he had the trophies to back it up
you know what I think about best of
wants their complete crap and there's no
competitive integrity - best of ones
they shouldn't take system this level of
game so anything can happen we can go
out we could be number eight because
best of ones doesn't show anything now
playing under g2 he led his roster to a
resounding victory at the inaugural six
major in Paris
are you close to getting the victory and
he goes down to will take the win I need
you the world stopped over with Gigi you
are unstoppable they went on to secure
season eight of pro league at which
point it simply felt as if save a few
blips no other roster had or would ever
stand a chance favorite can you guys be
stopped I mean sometimes it's gonna
happen I mean it happened in Atlantic
City
it's happened in Valencia and I can't
remember where we both saw powder that
was the last time we were in Brazil we
can't be stopped
yes not today but come the New Year
Jeter's performance had started to
plummet and the community was puzzled as
to why the only possible explanation it
felt was that jitu were simply so good
so dominant that Fabien had made the
ballsy decision to save strats until the
2019 invitation needless to say the
community was right
so we're terrible on paper right we've
been saving stress on purpose we've been
trying to innovate ourselves like really
restrictively and show a little skin as
possible so going to this tournament we
have a variety of maps that we haven't
exposed yet let's study on us we look
bad on paper and most importantly I
think all our ponens are extremely
scared because we are the reigning
champions for the second year in a row
they topped their group sailed through
the bracket and squashed the hopes of
their last remaining opponent a group of
feisty Russian hopefuls known as team
Empire for the time being there will be
great patience there you see it fabien
can't land the shots
there goes cars eka Shepards the last
one left he needs to get into the site
and keep in mind in a
[Applause]
to repeat as defending
world champions it doesn't matter the
region it doesn't matter the team it
doesn't matter the roster they will find
you and they will win
jeetu take the six invitational 2019
we're the best team in the world it
doesn't matter this is our stage we play
on stage we know what to do with the
pressure it's fine we won't Fabien had
reached the pinnacle he'd solidified
himself as the god emperor of his game
the problem is that like everyone who
undergoes a meteoric rise to the top
there was nowhere left to go but down it
was our stage I think that as long as
you believe you're the best team in the
world when you are on that level you
probably will be but as soon as you
start doubting yourself you're gonna
fall after emerging from the
invitational as the tournament's one and
only two time it seemed g2 were taking
their foot off the pedal again but this
time around it wasn't clear that it was
intentional it felt as if g2 might
actually be floundering for real I mean
we don't really care if we go to mean
I'm not sure it would be nice but it's
also nice to have a break six months or
whatever five months to the next major
yeah that's what we care about and
that's what we're gonna win you forgot
to Milan it's a bonus and I mean who
doesn't like some pocket money I
appreciate all the support from the fans
with you if we go there or not with
their pro league record still in
disrepair g2 didn't just fail to win the
season 9 finals they failed to qualify I
mean we've been saving so much strats
and we've been kind of taking a vacation
I went to Hawaii for three weeks and I
actually played from there now we've
just played bad come the six major in
Raleigh it felt as if g2 just couldn't
lose as if their dynasty couldn't falter
and siege was still squarely situated
under Fabian's rule and for a while that
was true you can't go through
construction and he turns the corner one
will lock him down it'll be Canada caddy
and that is g2 the reigning world
champions to the quarterfinals of the
Raleigh major shockwave completely
surrounded as the plant is going down
momentarily they will pull off an all
garage
GoGet closes it out the best support in
the world on the best Dean in the world
they have a rematch from the six
Invitational with Empire tomorrow but in
the grand finals it all came crashing
down joysticks still not aware of right
but it is two kills three for Shepard
and the Empire Strikes Back
they will take the Rowley major and
disbelief how quickly it comes I didn't
care I think we lost the event not
Empire winning it I think that we had
mental issues in the team and when it
comes to self confidence and possibility
to come back from them and therefore we
lost I don't think they want it reeling
from their loss in Raleigh G to fell off
even harder they failed to qualify for
their second Pro League final in a row
instigated several roster changes and
missed out on a whopping five
opportunities to defend their title at
the 2020 Invitational fabien and his
roster did end up making it to the
events but only because they were
offered a pity invite
well it is a pity invite but then again
it's also business more from universe
outside I think that no matter who they
would even I thought it would have been
controversial but then again it wouldn't
make sense to invite anyone else than us
we came second intro like be born the
last Invitational so we came third in
both pro leagues no matter who you
discussed for otherwise there's nobody
had those achievements even though we
were struggling last six months people
thought G 2 were washed a shadow of
their former selves I would say that
it's a low likelihood that g2 won't make
it past the quarters just based on past
performance there seems to be some kind
of magic with them in Montreal at this
event so who knows but as it turned out
Fabien still had a few tricks up his
sleeve can see it's a chunk of pick/ban
you know there I think that's a little
bit of a debate here we surely gonna see
yeah
okay we're gonna see it to chant
constructors I'm sure you've got plenty
of information about those in your
pocket so I'll let you talk to us sorry
about all the research I've done and
factors having me on my knees praying to
the Lord
much to the community surprised g2
exited the
group stage as undefeated hopefuls
Nuno's had such a good day so far has
got it all to do to close this one out
hitting in the right angle there as well
must surely know where is snuck away to
its ring around the rosies once again
Anna Bates out there with it the fuse
four seconds remaining ooh nope it's off
those where he is good for the girl uno
finds it g2 will go to zero and after
two matches will find themselves going
through to the playoffs as the first
European team to go there unfortunately
it wasn't enough
g2 lost both knockout series in quick
succession both times to an underdog
fabien x' roster just wasn't playing on
the same otherworldly level at once had
a very [ __ ] sick because for the last
three weeks I've been playing the best
siege of my life in practice I just met
and and then I come here and the worst
part is I'm not even feeling stressed in
the tumor spots but that's what I play
like gas seems like you didn't know
exactly what you want you have you chose
normally you have a good idea what to do
before your car is going around
finally after a year of struggle fabien
x' rain came to an end nobody's gonna be
as dominate this house again and we're
not gonna come back to it I don't think
so I would say that there's not gonna be
this sort of our ever again following
their elimination from the invitational
fabian and his org issued the most
shocking roster announcement siege had
ever seen jeju had benched Fabien
because he'd asked them to anyone
expected that Fabian would be leaving g2
he said that the team's atmosphere
wasn't great anymore and he just doesn't
think that they should play together
anymore Fabien is in no uncertain terms
the most accomplished captain strategist
and in-game leader in the history of
siege it isn't clear what his future
holds but what is clear is that it
doesn't feel like his story is coming to
an end it just feels like the start of a
new chapter
Fabien is probably one of the smartest
players that play Rainbow six right now
what he makes up for what he lacks in I
guess like mechanical skill or ability
he makes up for in game since he
probably has one of the highest game IQs
out of anybody period it remains to be
seen whether he'll be able to inspire
yet another Ross or to reach
lights but one thing is for certain
after winning everything after earning
the greatest titles and siege and
defending them Fabien remains as hungry
as ever
once again no you don't even have to
finish that question for me to answer it
I will never lose my motivation to be
the best I believe in myself I wouldn't
be here if I didn't think that I was the
best it doesn't matter what I think when
I go on stage if I think that I'm not
the best guy when I go into the or I'm
not gonna win it never know each other
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification Bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]